x-axis symmetry is that if you take the
graph and you fold it over the x-axis
you're reflected over the x-axis it will
match up with itself so for example say
for example your graph look like this if
you reflect it over the x-axis it
matches with itself this is a line of
symmetry the x-axis okay same thing with
the y-axis if you fold over the y-axis
the graph will match with itself and the
origin is like this for example if you
rotate it you pivoted about that origin
a hundred and eighty degrees like a half
turn it matches with itself so these are
the tests so what you do is you're
replacing your equation X with X Y with
negative Y and then when you simplify
your expression your equation if you get
back the original equation that tells
you that it has symmetry about that axis
or about that origin so if you want to
try to remember these a little bit
easier just go back to a simple point
here in the first quadrant X comma Y if
you reflect this over the x axis this
point would be positive x negative Y see
when you reflected over the x axis this
point will match up with X negative Y
and there you go that's your test y axis
you're going to fold it over the y axis
so you're going to be over here
negative x positive Y because you're
going to the left X but up the same
amount okay so that's your y-axis test
of an origin you're actually pivoting
180 degrees like this and so now this
point is going to be at negative x
negative Y okay and that's the test for
rotation about the origin so if you want
an easy way to remember just go back to
your coordinate axis system pick a
simple point here and look at what
happens when your reflect over the X to
the Y or rotate about the orange 180
degrees so let's take a look at a couple
examples and let's see if we can test
for the different types of symmetry that
this graph may or may not have so let's
take that first one x negative Y if we
substitute X with X we're gonna get x
squared Y was negative y okay now when
we simplify you can
see this is just going to be x squared
minus y equals 4 does this look like the
original equation nope it's a little
it's a little bit different because of
the negative Y so you can see that this
does not have x axis symmetry
let's do Y axis symmetry now so now
we're going to replace X with negative X
Y with positive y equals 4 so usually I
do a substitution I put it in
parenthesis so it's taken as a group or
as a whole a negative to an even power
is positive so this is going to be x
squared plus y equals 4 we have a match
that tells us that it's symmetric about
the y axis okay if you fold it over the
y axis it will match with itself and
then the last one the origin we're going
to make them both negative and if you
simplify this you get x squared minus y
equals 4 which again does not match the
original one so in this case you just
have y-axis symmetry I want to let you
know it could have more than one it
could have two it could have all three
it could just have none so you just have
to test them and see so let's look at
the next example this one here we've got
two X cubed minus five x equals y let's
replace X with X and Y with negative Y
so that's going to be okay if we
simplify we get two x cubed minus five x
equals negative Y even if we multiply
everything by negative one this would be
positive positive and negative okay
multiplied everything by negative one
still it doesn't look like the original
equation so it doesn't have x-axis
symmetry y-axis symmetry we're going to
replace X with negative X oops that's a
minus right there - okay if we simplify
this we get negative 2x cubed positive
five x equals y here you can see the
signs are again not the same so it
doesn't have a y-axis symmetry and the
last one origin symmetry we're going to
replace X with negative ax
okay Y with negative Y and if we
simplify we get a negative 2x cubed plus
5x equals negative y if we multiply
everything by negative one we're doing
it to both sides so we're not changing
the equation but we do change the way
that it looks slightly here now look
what we have here we have a match
okay these are exactly the same that
tells us that this graph is symmetric
about the origin 180 degree rotation
about the origin it will match with
itself similar to a graph like this
where you rotate it you're pivoting
about the origin and matches with itself
last one here x squared plus y squared
equals 9 so this one here we're going to
do this a little bit more intuitively
this time if we replace Y with negative
Y a negative squared is still positive
so you can see we're going to get back
the original equation so it does have
symmetry about the x axis
same thing with y-axis symmetry replace
X with negative x and y with positive y
the negative x squared is positive x
squared we're going to get back the same
equation okay good and then origin if we
make both the X and the y negative still
these are raised to even powers they're
going to be positive this equation will
be the same so what this tells you it
actually has symmetry about the x axis Y
accent axis and the origin and we know
this from previous video about circles
this is just the equation of a circle
with radius 3c square root of 9 is 3 and
we know that if you fold it over the y
axis fold it over the x axis or rotate
it 180 degrees this graph will match
with itself so this has been an overview
about how to find the symmetry and
graphs given the equation using the
symmetry tests if you have any questions
review it again take another look and
I'll see you in the next video